jeff bezos is the single richest person
in modern history and his company amazon
was the second company in history to
reach a market cap
of one trillion dollars he went from
being the son of a 17 year old high
school student
and cuban immigrant stepfather to now
having a net worth of 161.1
billion dollars
need motivation watch your top 10
with believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carl michael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious
person that you know but you also know
that you're capable of more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best jeff bezos and my take on his top
10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one be stubborn
on your vision be stubborn on vision and
flexible on details
the um you really can't accomplish
anything
important if you're not stubborn on
vision because things that are important
take a long time
you take teams you can't do it by
yourself and so you really need to
you need to have a crisp idea of the
vision you need to stay incredibly
relentless on that vision
but you need to be flexible on the
details because
you've got to be experimental to
accomplish anything important
and that means you're going to be wrong
a lot and so you're going to try
something
on your way to that vision and that's
going to be the wrong thing the wrong
decision you're going to have to back up
take a little course correction and try
again
and so you cannot be stubborn on the
details
you have to be flexible on the details
rule number two
choose to do hard things a young person
starting their career
i think there are probably a lot of
things that some of them
are very well known and people have
heard them many times they're still true
one of those that you should always
focus on a young person should find
something that they're passionate about
to do and
that's not going to surprise anyone it's
it's a clear thing to do it's very hard
if you don't love your work you're never
going to be great at it
i think the other thing i would suggest
to any young person even before they
start their career
is to really think about their choices
because i find young people and i
i when i was young i had i made this
mistake too
you can get very fixed on your
gifts so everybody has gifts you know
you you have gifts
you have things that you didn't get
gifted maybe you're extremely beautiful
maybe you're
extremely good at mathematics maybe you
there are a lot of things that you can
be given
but those things can confuse you because
they're not the things that construct
your life it's your choices
that construct your life not your gifts
you can celebrate your gifts be proud of
them be happy of them
actually don't be proud of them be be
celebratory of them because you can't be
proud because they're gifts they were
given to you you didn't earn
them you can only be proud of the things
you earn
and so as i got older i started to
realize i wasn't proud of my
gifts i was always good at school school
was always easy for me
and i was always proud that i was a
great student i got a's in all my
classes
i was good at math all of that and i
thought
i thought that's who i was but it's not
true
those are the things that are gifts what
was hard for me is deciding to work hard
deciding to use my gifts in certain ways
to challenge myself to do things that i
didn't think i could do to put myself in
uncomfortable situations
we all get i would say to a young person
you can choose a life
of ease and comfort or you can choose a
life of service
and adventure which one of those when
you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of rule
number three keep
working backwards look we would all love
all of our numbers to be smooth
lines up and to the right and uh that
would be terrific but
that's not how it works you know um you
know the
those numbers are are output
measures and you i mean i guess you
could try to manage your quarterly
earnings
very precisely but i i think personally
that would be a mistake you know most of
the work that we put into um any
particular quarter
happened years ago so it's not you know
there's there aren't that many knobs you
can turn during a quarter i mean you can
but they're very they're like eating
your seed corn
if you turn those knobs you don't want
to do that and so
uh it's it's uh i
you know people i think if you focus on
the controllable inputs to your business
instead of the outputs
in the long term you get better results
so the
the benjamin graham quote here is that
in the short term the
stock market is a voting machine in the
long term it's a weighing machine
and i think people are well advised to
build a company that wants to be weighed
and not voted upon
and that means having good return on
invested capital and having
you know lots of free cash flow but if
you said to me if i said
here's a job i would reject if somebody
came to me and said jeff i want your job
to be to drive up the amazon stock price
and just manage that directly now this
might sound ridiculous to some of you
but many companies actually do this they
have
they actually go out and they try to
sell the stock that's kind of the final
output and it's much better to say
okay let's not do that that's not going
to be sustainable it's kind of a silly
approach
um what are the inputs to a higher
stock price and he said okay well
pre-cash flow and
return on invested capital inputs to a
higher stock price okay
so let's let's keep working backwards
what are the inputs to free cash flow
and you keep working backwards until you
get to something that's controllable
and a controllable input for free cash
flow would be something like lower cost
structure
and you back up from there and you say
okay well you know if we can improve our
picking efficiency and our fulfillment
centers and reduce defects
defects are very very costly it's
probably you know reducing defects at
the root is one of the best ways to
lower cost structure
and so if you then that starts to be a
job you would accept
you would say if you're you know a
reasonable person you would say i have
no idea how to
uh drive up the stock price i can't
manage that directly it's not a
controllable input
but i i can make your picking algorithms
more efficient
and that will reduce cost structure and
then you know
follow that chain all along the way
that's what you do
in all of these businesses rule number
four learn from trial and error
failure and invention are inseparable
twins
you know it's everybody wants to
be inventive you know if you go talk to
corporate america or
any any institution actually government
agencies and so on
innovation is something to be proud of
people like invention
but the problem is they don't like
failure
and you cannot have invention without
failure
if you uh
to know where if you already know it's
gonna work it's not an experiment
and only through experimentation can you
get real invention
the most important inventions come from
trial and error
with lots of failure and and the failure
is critical
um and it's also embarrassing and so
that's why
people in when we're kids
we always are doing trial and error and
we're never embarrassed
you know if you watch a little toddler
and they will try for hours to put a
square peg in a round hole
and it never works but doesn't keep them
from trying
and they try things like that and that's
how they learn and
uh and and we all have that when we're
little and then as we get older somehow
it's not as cool as you get older to
fail and to fall down it looks clumsy
and so we get in our grooves we have a
set of expertise and skills it's kind of
a comfort zone
and you have to constantly push yourself
to say no
i don't care about failure in fact if
you know i say at amazon
we have to grow the size of our failures
as the size of our company grows we have
to make bigger and bigger
failures because otherwise none of our
failures will be needle movers
and so i would see it as a very bad sign
over the long run
if amazon wasn't making larger and
larger failures
and if you do that all along the way
that is going to protect you from ever
having to make
that big you know kind of hail mary bet
that you sometimes see
companies make right before they fail
and
go out of existence also if you want
more self-love
unstoppable confidence and learn from
billionaires check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join on the description
below if everything has to work in two
to three years
then that limits what you can do if you
absolutely can't tolerate critics then
don't do anything
new or interesting the number one thing
that has made us successful
by far is obsessive compulsive
focus on the customer rule number five
learn from your elders
my the most influential people in my
life were
my grandparents and i have a my
mother had me when she was 17 years old
she raised me
with my grandparents help and she was
still in high school when she had me
that was not
cool in albuquerque new mexico in 1964
but she did an incredible job but i was
lucky because i had not just her
but i had she re she married my father
when i was about
four years old he has been a huge
influence in my life but my grandmother
and grandfather
were like second set of parents for me
and you learn different things from them
because they're at a different stage of
life and they know different things
they're calm about certain things
it was a huge gift to me
my grandfather was a
had a ranch in texas and i spent all my
summers there from like age 4 to 16
and he was the most self-reliant person
he did all of his own veterinary work
all the things i mean and to
observe him solve problems and figure
out how to do things with no tools and
no
resources and you know very small
amounts of money it was
a huge education from an early age so
we're very like
see one of the things that you i know
people who have
they don't have great family situations
and sometimes they break that cycle
and they are the ones who pull out of it
those
people are the ones i reserve my highest
admiration for
rule number six don't do things you'd
regret
as the owner of the post i know that at
times the post is going to write stories
they're going to
uh make very powerful people very
unhappy
are you upset if they are writing
critical stories about amazon which i do
no
i'm not upset at all when i first bought
the pictures
and i'd never i would be humiliated to
interfere i would be so embarrassed i
would
i would turn bright red and it has
nothing to do
with um i don't even get so far i just
don't want to for me it would feel icky
it would feel gross it would feel it
would be one of those things when i'm 80
years old
i would be so unhappy with myself if i
interfered
why would i i want that paper to be
independent
rule number seven have multiple paths to
yes
amazon one of the things we try to do is
have
multiple paths to yes and so
here's here's a little thought
experiment for you
if you are a junior
executive at amazon and if
amazon did this in the typical kind of
corporate hierarchy way
you had an idea you need to get your
boss
to green light that idea and then your
boss's boss
needs to green light that idea and then
your boss's boss's boss
needs to greenlight that idea they're
probably five levels
or more before that idea gets the
go-ahead
assume instead that you're an
entrepreneur with a startup company idea
and you need venture capital you go to
sandhill road
and you go to the first venture
capitalist and they tell you no
and you go to the second one and they
tell you no
you're maybe your 20th one tells you yes
you've got 19 no's and one yes
and you're still good to go so that
that venture capital model is there's
multiple paths to yes there were 20
people who could give you a yes
and it didn't matter how many gave you a
no so if you want innovative thinking
you have to think about how can we get
you want hi
you want a large number of high judgment
people empowered to green light things
you want multiple paths to yes you want
a system where
as a junior air force officer with a
good idea
the first five people tell me no and
somehow i can still go pursue that idea
so you gotta figure out that's an
organizational um
uh challenge that big organizations have
to figure out a way to do and by the way
i get you know this happens all the time
i'll say i don't think that's a good
idea
but somebody else will greenlight it and
i'm fine with that because usually
the cost of the experiments is pretty
small
things only get expensive when they work
right once something works you're like
whoa we need to double down on that now
and then the spending can get heavy and
then those become big consequential
decisions and that's where the hierarchy
and the
using the judgment of the most senior
people to me this really helps
rule number eight build a multitude of
small teams
well two pizza teams is something that
we've been preaching at amazon
almost from the very beginning and it's
a simple idea which is
no team should be so large that it
cannot be fed with just two pizzas
and uh and so obviously to do great
things you need big teams
but you need to subdivide them and the
reason that it's so helpful is because
there's a natural we humans grew up
around campfires and telling each other
stories
and you're sitting at tables tonight
that have about 10 people at each table
10 people maybe 12 people is the perfect
size
to have a natural human coordination
without a lot of structure and if you
want to have a
big group of 100 people or 500 people
organized you have to have a lot of
structure to make that work
and so if you can arrange to do big
things
with a multitude of small teams and that
takes a lot of effort to organize that
way
but if you can figure that out the
communication on those small teams will
be very natural and easy
rule number nine be clear about what you
want
warren buffett has this great quote he
says you can hold a
rock concert and that's okay and you can
hold a ballet
and that's okay just don't hold a rock
concert and advertise it as a ballet
investors come in all shapes and sizes
they have
different investment horizons different
approaches different
beliefs about what the right kind of
portfolio
looks like and so it's not one you know
people
use wall street as a shorthand but there
isn't one type of investor
they come in all shapes and sizes and
you have to be super clear
about what kind of company you're trying
to build what your approach is we laid
that out in our 1997 annual shareholder
letter
we said we were going to take big bets
we said they were going to fail
we said some of them hopefully were
going to work we said we were going to
invest
for the long term that we were going to
try to take advantage of
market opportunities as they arose and
there's a certain kind of investor
who is aligned with that approach and so
again
you can hold the ballet or the rock
concert and both can work
um just be clear about which one you are
and then people can self select
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have fun zoey would you cast him in a
film
yeah yeah yeah and give him a speaking
line
i wouldn't yeah it has to be pivotal
pivotal i don't want to end up on the
cutting room floor
okay we would you would you audition for
it
what would you audition for this role
yeah of course of course i'm
i'm coming there i'm right now ladies
and gentlemen
wait gentlemen now you want me to
audition
now time jeff time we don't have time we
have to listen now
okay i have now i'm intimidated no no no
no no no
okay okay so the line is a film her
brother directed i acted in
okay and because you're so busy and
we're extremely thankful all of us
including me and zoya everyone backstage
for giving us your valuable time
it is impossible to get a gentleman like
this who's so inspiring so wonderful
telling us such nice anecdotes from his
life
and talking about business and to young
entrepreneurs and all the youngsters who
are listening to this
because his time is so precious it's
difficult to catch him the line is
in hindi no say after me in hindi yeah
this is this is the
alien language you have to speak in
right
and we'll put the universal thingy on
you
so it is jeff ko
jeff ko jeff ko jeff ko
pakarna bakana
[Music]
impossible hey absolutely guys
jeff bezos now i've got a special bonus
tip from jeff
on how to spend your time wisely that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day
i wanna know what is the hard thing that
you need to step up and just do
let me know what that is put it down in
the comments below and if you made it
this far in a video you're still here
watching
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below
i want to celebrate you we don't just
watch videos here
we do something about it so give me that
believe in the comments below too
we don't meet with our biggest investors
we meet with
investors who have low portfolio turns
so you know
investors that have you know many
investors many investment funds
have very high portfolio turns they turn
their portfolio multiple times per year
they're not really investors they're
traders there's nothing wrong with that
it's just a different thing
but where are you going to spend your
time your energy is one of the most
important decisions you get to make in
life we all have a limited amount of
time
where you spend it and how you spend it
is is
just an incredibly levered way to think
about the world and
so if you're gonna spend time you know
uh explaining the stock
and or the company really we don't
really explain the stock we explain the
company
to people you should do it to people who
are long-term investors
rather than traders that's our point of
view
[Music]
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer
on this channel i have a dedicated brand
new channel just for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out continue to believe
and i'll see you there